I just bought a crisis keeps getting
worse he knows just who to blame New
York City now Department of Homeland
Security Source is apparently telling
NBC news that New York's handling of
illegal immigrants was not operationally
sound and is quote no exit strategy for
illegals Joe is sending them this comes
after New York city mayor Eric Adams
revealed that he's not spoken to Biden
in months that says Pennsylvania is now
just recovering from a nearly two-week
Manhunt for a deranged illegal immigrant
killer who escaped from that prison
every state now is a border state thanks
to Joe Biden's failed border policies
all right joining us now live in studio
the governor of the very great and Free
State of Florida
well I just want you to know when I came
out I did not get a standing ovation and
it's my show I don't know
is there any policy you can think that
Joe Biden's implemented that is working
because I just see nothing but exactly I
mean dumb question right so I mean this
border is such a disaster and so what
I've said is day one as president we're
declaring it a National Emergency I'm
sending the military down to the Border
we're going to build the wall Stop The
Invasion but I am going to treat the
Mexican drug cartels as the foreign
terrorist groups that they are they're
killing tens of thousands of our fellow
citizens by bringing fentanyl into this
country we're using lethal Force against
the cartels if they're bringing fentanyl
in breaking into our country we're going
to leave them stone cold dead at the
border trust me they will get the
message
how do you assess the state of of the
primary as of right now
um and and what do you want people to
know about you that maybe they don't
know
well I was the reason I'm in New York is
because I got invited to be at the 911
ceremony remembrance ceremy with some of
the 911 families so my wife and I got to
go and we're looking at the names and
they're telling stories Joe Biden was in
Hanoi yeah and then he went to Alaska or
something like that and nine I was you
know far away from it I didn't have
anyone I knew but it was a huge impact
on me that I ended up joining the
military as a result of that and I
always had put myself in a position I
could have made a lot of money but I
decided you know our country's in
Conflict uh we don't have a draft but
I'm going to step up and do whatever
part I can and so that kind of put me on
the road to service and so throughout my
career I've always put service above
self I mean I think I am the leader I am
the vehicle but ultimately it's not
about me uh it's about delivering for
the people that I represent and in this
case uh turning this country around
because this country and you and I have
talked about it it's in Decline uh we're
uh it's Jeopardy scary we're in Jeopardy
of being the first generation of
Americans who are going to turn over to
our kids and grandkids and America less
prosperous and less free than what we
inherited and and that would be a
tragedy if we allowed that to happen so
we got to reverse the decline we need to
get America on a different path and
that's that's my mission that's why I'm
running the back and forth I'll be
honest I'm loving it because it's we're
almost finished and ready to announce
hopefully soon a date with you and and
uh Gavin Newsom having a debate you like
that idea I like it
um and I'm glad you accept it
and there's such I don't know how you
reconcile open Borders or secure borders
uh Law and Order or defund the police
how do you reconcile energy Independence
and this this you know climate alarmist
religious cult where's where's the
middle ground on these issues well look
I think the California Florida is very
instructive Sean we just had an almost
category 4 hurricane hit our state uh a
week after that hurricane hit we had a
higher percentage of our population with
power than California did of theirs and
we had to recover from a storm going
through so their policies aren't working
they're driving people away from
California and I remember as Governor I
grew up in Florida I never saw a
California license plate all of a sudden
I'm Governor we see all these California
license plates in my state and a lot of
my voters were very upset about that
because they didn't know how these
people were going to vote well it turns
out you know these are people that are
we're leaving because the policies were
so bad and they embraced the free state
of Florida and a lot of them came came
and voted for me but what if you could
make a law that says if you come from
one of these left-wing States uh you
have to pledge not to bring the idiotic
policies you left behind
so
during don't ruin the state that you're
moving to during during like the last
few years there would be uh people of
our ilk who would go to supermarkets in
Florida they would find any car with a
New York Plate and they would put a
flyer in the windshield saying don't
vote down here the way they vote up
there because people but I'll tell you I
think if you look at my election you
know we won the biggest Republican
landslide in the history of Florida
Governor's races I think a lot of the
people that are moving are moving
and your first race in 2018 was was very
close uh as was Rick Scott's that year
his was closer than yours I think he won
by what ten thousand and his other
Governor's races Trump and 16 they were
all one-point races that was the reality
of Florida you've covered all these
races at Florida was always on a knife's
edge and I think what we showed in
Florida is something we can show for the
country if you lead with purpose and
conviction if you stand for these strong
policies and deliver you move people to
your side we won Miami-Dade County by
double digits we won for the first time
in 40 years as a republican Palm Beach
County nobody thought you could do that
so it can be done and I think our
country right now it's kind of like the
late 70s were failing we're floundering
we got a very weak leader in the White
House a lot of people said America's
best days are behind us Ronald Reagan
said no we can we can get it done and I
think we're in the same period I think a
majority of the public wants to see a
new Direction and I think we have a
chance to really move the country
forward let me ask you this and I I
think this is a very pivotal question
for the country moving forward making
this choice about I don't know if this
country can survive four more years of
Biden and his policies that's how
dangerous I think it is for the country
never felt that before and I've been
doing this a long time so I get to talk
to a lot of people now on the campaign
trail and I had a woman tell me that now
at the grocery store it's not about what
she can put into her cart it's what once
she's checking out and the the total
starts getting rung up and it's so high
the things she has to take out of her
cart because you just can't afford it
anymore 61 percent of Americans paycheck
to paycheck families who uh want to buy
a home but their mortgage payment
monthly would be double what that
similar home would have been four or
five years ago people can't afford new
cars that's by Dynamics in a nutshell he
wants to pursue his ideological agenda
for his friends meanwhile American
standard of living suffers and if we
continue going down this direction
American working people are going to be
put in a deeper hole so you're going to
debate Gavin Newsom yes we're going to
do it it's going to be fun looking
forward to it Governor great to see in
New York hey please come back hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else